and you know the thing that kids are
into now again when I talk to these kids
it's all Danny's and pills and [ __ ]
tied things I'm amazing yeah they're
eating time like I'm amazed at how many
people do like human beings have always
always tried to get out of their state
right they've always wanted to get into
another state it goes back so far human
beings have always experimental themed
lands drugs kappa everything drugs that
seemed part of being human experiences
to kind of get out of your sober state
the Indians did some [ __ ] aside the
peyote the losing and and what's
fascinating is that it's no different
now but I feel like there's a spiritual
malaise I think that a huge part of it
maybe I'm an old guy talking but I think
that there I feels like two things are
going on one is people feel like they're
completely powerless to control anything
around them because of the the world
that's so big and so much to machine and
also I think people are very confused on
purpose I don't think there's I think a
lot of people are missing purpose I
agree here's the other thing is now
social media before if I was just a kid
from Denver
I saw what everyone had going on around
me in Denver well now again social media
I see what Billy in Florida is doing I'm
like oh my god but now no no I can't
hear myself but I can see what Kylie
Jenner looks like when she wakes up in
the one who house or bed her clothes her
cars so now yours
you're looking at that going well [ __ ] I
have this man now why suicide so high
right now when did it'd be cool to kill
yourself what in the [ __ ] are we doing I
think it's a spiritual malaise I think
it's like when you feel like nothing you
do matters when you feel like nothing
you do can contribute to anything when
you feel like you don't matter like your
existence doesn't matter in a world
that's great you're great with
everything for one piece of your and and
that there used to be I think a way out
of that which was there's a way to stop
you be there is the way out but I think
because we gravitate towards negativity
but just as much negativity that there's
on social media there's much more
positive yeah but we're brains are we
gravitate towards negativity and then
activity they want to huddle together
negativity they want the club together
if you look at if someone posts a
negative post there's gonna be a bunch
more them but someone's waiting for them
because they want to be part of that
club because there's something going on
in their life but again this this is
just if I want to find activity I can go
down a whole horrible rabbit or ironic
or I used to avoid all of it and I can
find positivity put your phone down you
put your phone down but if let's say
you're a young kid and you you're gonna
be on your phone you find more positive
than a gas you're sure that's true and
you Wade Mayweather is back in the news
again so for the last two days yesterday
he posted this picture of Conor McGregor
and him interception goes in there let
me refresh this real quick so it's just
him and Connor his in his hashtag MCM
man crush Monday it says Mayweather
crushes McGregor it's so weird I don't
know why he doesn't get over it so that
was yesterday and then today he posts
this video of him just casually walking
into a no description at all
ladies that syndicate in Las Vegas yeah
yeah so that's what's going on with
Floyd Mayweather right now he's just
teasing it oh my god what in the world
are we doing what are we doing a postman
this is before that yeah oh man
I just I don't know what to make of it
yeah I don't want to see him fight in
the UFC really you do I mean yeah just
to get just because you know what about
him CM Punk and he beats the Impala that
would be the craziest it'd be like a
[ __ ] yeah the biggest [ __ ] show for sure
again when we're in this WME world side
i don't put it past them their time at
CM Punk to get another fight i I do know
that if he did fight CM Punk
or McGregor I'm sure all of us would be
watchin in hit ratings McGregor vs. him
and in the UFC and a mixed martial arts
fight I mean that's that that'd be super
silly for super-silly he's not that dumb
he's just he's just trying to stay
relevant he's just trying to be in the
news that's the the you see doesn't
really know how to promote black
fighters yet they've had that problem
for a long time and I sat down with Dana
myself right before the Tony Ferguson
fighting I told him I'm like you know if
you looking for somebody like your boy
holla at your boy what do you think they
need to do because I'm trying to think
let's go over some of the the big
african-american fighter so Jon Jones
I'll see the biggest right right he kind
of market himself with the bad-boy image
just constantly [ __ ] up but you see I
mean John has become a star since then
you know people really got on his on his
side I'm just starved because everyone
likes a redemption story I don't know if
John's a star if we actually met the
real John Jones I think once he embraced
that and you kind of seen that a little
bit more with that press conference we
were a part of it
people loved it once he embraced the
realness it was it was when he was doing
that the Jesus stuff holy in all this
and it's just like bro
you'd come off but he thought he was so
if you think about the but he's probably
the biggest african-american drawl right
John Jones and then who are so yacht
yacht Woodley got DC which I cannot
figure out why DC's not a bigger draw
yeah I mean it's it's something I don't
know I mean I like you I like the
example that's probably it's probably
he's a little bit older you know you
went 3d he spent most of his life
wrestling in the Olympics yeah so he's a
little bit older and it's just it's kind
of hard to get behind him you know she's
like I don't know what it is that you
need that young face but I don't I don't
think it's many in the game right now I
think I mean I'm few and far between you
know I think they've been trying to do a
lot of stuff with me and I Tyrone would
do a lot better if he stopped
complaining so got rich like I tell them
that himself like Tyra I'm gonna text
you after this it's like the only
argument that you might have with
african-american fighters not the only
one the major ones be Mighty Mouse yeah
how's it because he's African Americans
cuz he's a hundred pounds I think
honestly what it is is Mighty Mouse
tries but he really don't give a [ __ ]
you know my team all says he's
comfortable you know he's got his wife
he's got his kids he's got his house
he's he's got money in the bank right
his champion of all time greatest evil
say he's got the record for title
defenses I think he cares more about the
competition aspect of it did anything
and he really just don't give a [ __ ]
about it which is cool I mean if you
don't like he's so talented
yeah you know like any D does try you
know we've done the metro show a couple
of times I've got to hang out with him
you know he was co-main under nicest guy
at a fight so I I was trying to give him
like pointers on what to what to do how
to how to act what to say an artist and
he really don't give you that I don't
care you don't care if I'm play these
video games get these belts which is
cool cost me 16 dollars by the way get
it up your ass
get that put it in your ass man I'm not
doing whatever if I come back here next
time and that thing doesn't smell like
[ __ ] I will slap you raw on your [ __ ]
podcast man that thing better
like the inside of your [ __ ] food
hole sweep I don't give a [ __ ] your hand
get that [ __ ] Ward up your ass bryan
callen hearing cats give a [ __ ] what
your opinion is you're fake news you're
fake news here's your [ __ ] award
you wanna [ __ ] up your [ __ ] in one
fell swoop as a matter of fact you know
what
just put the head of it in your tight
little balloon and then just jump up and
sit on a I mean okay I'm sorry I want to
apologize to MJ
sorry who's a young intern with her life
ahead of her and she's being exposed to
this [ __ ] heathen ogre yeah and I'm
sorry
look you got candles around here you got
five candles I'm French Johnny my Jenna
friend Johnny was a really special guy
and he said seven don't give anybody too
much power of you and I said why they
said because when people have all the
power of you they'll do terrible things
here I said that's probably true and he
said they'll reach in your ass and
polish it up yeah a friend who says
bizarre [ __ ] I go he said some amazing
things I go what he goes they'll just
reach in your ass and pull his [ __ ] out
of it I go things that somebody that's
power of you would do I don't think the
reason he hasn't pulled [ __ ] I don't
think that's possible doesn't make sense
come up with about Dennett we were
driving then why doesn't well you know
Charlie Johnny oh yeah Johnny from the
neighborhood about Johnny fabulous and
he goes he guys were driving and I was
like 40 and he was you know 48 and he
goes all seriousness he looks at me he
goes we should start a band who know and
I go that's a really good idea and he
goes yep and I go what would I play goes
I would imagine whatever you know I go
what would you do and he goes I would
sing I go alright we just kept driving
and then I was lying in the bed and he
goes what's going on girl my legs are so
sore I worked out and he reached down
and began to rub my ankles and I go
Jesus that feels good and he goes I know
because I'm rubbing the connective
tissue in your legs and I go goddamn it
and he goes I always wanted to write a
novel about that and I went alright
so those are the things and the fourth
thing he said was he said I gotta get
out of LA and I said why and he said
because I get really tired of fixing
things with my eyes nobody knows how to
make anything beautiful around here and
he was a hunter and he was he was he's
on the spectrum but one of the most
beautiful people ever met and he sounds
like he's on the special I loved it and
I [ __ ] loved it I wait please say
that again
my eyes what I have to fix things with
hurt he said I gotta get out of LA I
said why goes because my eyes are hurt
because I'm fixing things all the day
all day cuz know was how to make
anything beautiful yeah he's on the
spectrum right now but he was right yeah
there's no flow here no there's no flow
from one thing to another yeah just a
bunch of little islands ya know yeah
that's true little islands little little
punk you put a price I'm making
beautiful beautiful things right you
can't put a price on creating beauty all
[ __ ] aside